in the world of internet science wizard
breast pub nothing is quite what it
seems like this ruler
and this knife
we're one step closer to an invisibility
cloak this is one of my favorite clips
because the physics is so smart
press pups invisibility device
confounded 1 million viewers online but
how does it work normally we see things
because they either emit light like my
smile or they reflect light like my
smile in this case neither of these
things are happening
what frost pup has done is use the set
of lenses so that there are certain
places he can hold objects so that the
light reflected from them never reaches
the camera but more importantly the
light from behind the object does reach
the camera and it gives the illusion of
that object having disappeared so how
did BrussPup pull this off and BrussPup
setup he asked for lenses and a camera
the light from the background enters the
first lens it gets flipped upside down
it's sent from the second lens to the
third lens between the third and fourth
lens it's focused down onto a point and
flipped upside down again by the time it
comes out of the fourth lens it's no
longer distorted it looks exactly as it
should do if there weren't any lenses in
between the area between the lenses but
outside the beam of light is known as
the cloaking region and this is because
any light that enters the last lens from
this region does not make it to the
camera
it's those points he can put in a knife
his hand a laser and they will disappear
you